In modern times we tend to have cells
All living organisms consist of cells
Human beings and all living organisms are made up of many cells
Cells in the human body are estimated at 37 trillion cells!
But if we return 400 years ago in the 1960s
This was not clear
Because people did not have enough tools
To study the cells and did not know their existence
Nor were they aware of the existence of organisms such as single cells
But all that changed with Robert Hook
When he could invent a primitive microscope
This is the microscope image
See how similar
Modern microscope
The microscope has lenses to enlarge
But Robert had to use - this torch to direct the light
To reflect on what he is watching
In 1665, Robert published "microscopy".
Maybe you did not type the name correctly
This is the year 1665 where Robert Hook describes
And draws a lot of
Of his observations using an engraver
Robert has some amazing graphics where he was a good painter
He was able to draw pictures
Of his observations, such as lice, fleas.
But he did not watch only lice and fleas
But was able to observe the so-called piles or what he saw as cufflinks
When he noticed something, he said, "Look at these little squares here
"It reminds me of the little rooms called cells
So Robert called them cells
Hence came the label
Cells in the "microscopy".
This is the cell
Unfortunately, Robert was a wonderful artist
It was good at drawing things
Drawing a lot using "microscopy" but do not have any pictures of Robert Hook
It is a wonderful story where most novels claim
That Isaac Newton burned the only original painting of Robert Hook.
It's an interesting story that we'll talk about later
Robert Hook discovered "cells" - but he was looking at the dead tissue, and actually he was
Look at the cell residue. What he saw was just the remnants of the cell wall.
He was not able to observe the "living cells" directly he was wondering
"Maybe this is a stone building in life and cells multiply by themselves"
"The cells produce other cells." We need to go deeper into history to see the evolution of these stages
A few years later Anthony von Ewenhoek appeared.
He may not have pronounced his name correctly
He was a Dutch lens maker, and the work of Robert Hook was an inspiration
"Hey, I can make the lenses to make the microscopes better, so I watch better."
He was able to do this, and already he watched
Living cells and single - cell organisms.
And watch the sperm.
"This thing seems alive," he said,
It was able to monitor cells directly - these single-cell and eukaryotic cells ...
Which have walls of cells, and these things look like single-celled animals.
They were called "microscopic animals".
He said, "Hey, it looks like these little animals that are going on here."
"Maybe this is a basic form of life," he said,
Or on this basis there is life
But the modern theory of cells appeared only after 100-150 years
Here we are in the early 1980s
If we progress quickly to the year 1830. These two men Matthias Schladin and Theodore Xuan
Laying the foundation
What we call today "modern cell theory".
Modern cell theory
Based on their observations and conclusions
They said, "Perhaps all organisms are made up
Of one or more cells ".
Today we are sure of this but it was not clear
It was not clear that these things were the foundation stone of life
Since life consists of one or more cells,
It can also be said that the cell, is the basic unit of life.
Cell is the basic unit of life
These powerful statements that all life forms from the smallest things
Consists of the cells that make up life.
Well, the theory is not yet complete. These two men learned that the cells are made up of other cells
They were able to control cell proliferation however
The question still exists "Maybe some cells are produced by other cells, while some are automatically made up of themselves in one way or another
If the elements and conditions are appropriate these cells appear from nowhere
Modern cell theory only emerged in the mid 1800s
The idea is that all cells are produced from other cells.
All cells are produced from other cells
And the true founder who proved this idea
This guy is here, Robert Remac.
Sometimes thanks to this man Rudolph Verschau but turned out to be
He stole the work from Remac, so the biggest credit to Remac
At this stage all cells come from other cells.
Again, I was not the first person to say "hey, we will note that some cells ..
Produced from other cells. "But he said:" This is the basic thing, all cells appear on their own "
In our world today, people see
That cells are produced from other cells
It is normal to ask "Is there a first cell or an initial set of" cell model? "He said.
People were not so sure but if
Going back, to the evolution of life on earth, it is possible that the first cells emerged about three and a half billion years ago.
And we are not quite sure of the way it appeared, but there are some theories that explain:
For example, there are videos on phosphatic lipids,
Phosphate lipids were formed from the double layers
In fact, they are made up of spherical membranes made up of double phosphorous layers.
Here the beginning, so that can be formed spontaneously.
There are also theories that explain the mechanism of action of cells
Maybe if we came back three and a half billion years ago
RNA molecules may be self-replicating or perhaps self-replicating proteins
With a lot of time passing
Was able to start repeating itself as it had more sophisticated mechanisms,
Those that have formed modern cells and are able to produce more,
They were able to utilize more energy, resources and environment.
Finally we end up getting modern cells but this wonderful question is still under consideration.